du météo grave de thé seront d'abord à
la sonde semi-automatique 120 ans
d'histoire en météorologiques
general besson c'était quelque chose de
très simple et très gros aussi qu'ils
aient à peu près 4 kg qui était grand
comme ça qu'on a envoyés jusqu'à 12 km
accroché à un ballon au départ sa mesure
est que la température
après progressivement on a rajouté la
prise de mesure de la pression en même
temps dessus et on est arrivé à la
première radio song le site de trappes
conserve aujourd'hui encore les vieilles
sonde l'une des plus anciennes est
pourtant toujours d'actualité celle
utilisée lors de l'année polaire de 1932
imaginé et créé par jules richard
industriels français les sondes ne
viennent plus compact et plus
sophistiquées c'est aussi le cas des
ballons si on regarde par exemple des
seringues de bord avec ses ballons qui
était très gros qu'ils aient 26 mètres
cubes
il y a cinq pour cent de ces ballons
quand dépasser les 20 kilomètres
d'altitude alors que ensuite avec ce
qu'on a utilisées progressivement avec
la miniaturisation des radios sont on
arrive maintenant
résultat où on a quasiment 100% des
ballons qui dépasse les 25 km il y en a
beaucoup qui arrive à 30 km d'altitude
et ça avec deux mètres cubes maximum de
gaza utilisé depuis quelques mois
l'envoi de ballon est devenu
semi-automatique toujours préparé par
l'homme les sondes sont aujourd'hui
envoyées automatiquement
elles ont une vitesse constante de 300
mètres par minute en évaluant
température pression humidité ainsi que
la vitesse et la direction du vent
les capteurs doivent atteindre au
minimum 20 kilomètres d'altitude et
c'est dans cette salle que les données
sont réceptionnés avant d'être analysée
par les prévisionnistes pendant en gros
une heure 45 à 2 heures elle va
continuer tout au cours de sa montée
elle va faire des mesures de température
de pression d'humidité qu'on peut voir
en direct sur l'écran du sondage qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure avec en rouge des
courbes d'humidité et en blanc la courbe
de température de ballons avec la
pression qui vit nu va augmenter de
volume jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où il va
éclater pour l'année 2016 année
bissextile 732 ballons sondes seront
envoyées ils continueront ainsi à faire
la pluie et le beau temps ou du moins de
le prévoir